let's let's get right to it because
there's a key date coming up next week
for the green bay packers
mandatory minicamp not voluntary all
this talk about
otas and who's going to show up and
who's not going to show up that takes a
back seat because now thou shalt attend
and if you don't if you skip the
mandatory mini camp you're looking at 93
000 in fines plus you can be called out
you can be chastised publicly sure by
your coaches if you skip the mandatory
mini camp so chris the biggest name when
it comes to who will or won't be at
mandatory mini camp this year oh
aaron rodgers and yesterday
coach matt lafleur
talking about the possibility or not
that rogers will be at next week's
mandatory mini camp here's the floor
how important is it for you to have
aaron rodgers out there practicing with
the team next week
oh i think it's like i said it's
important that we have all our guys and
certainly uh
you know we'd love them to be here and
uh you know hopefully we'll see them
tuesday
yeah not a whole lot of conviction
yeah i mean come on right you know he
could he could say all he wants yeah it
is important for all the guys to be
there they want aaron rodgers to be
there of course he's the leader of the
team as he's said many of times he's
kind of the blood you know that he's
he's the soul the heart and soul of the
team and then i think also too mike that
you know things that
maybe the public doesn't realize why you
love a guy like aaron rodgers at
practice it usually raises the level of
practice that's why it's a great thing
to have that guy there because
everybody's like oh wait rogers is here
we got to get on our game the receivers
the linemen they know that you know yeah
the coach might yell at me but rogers
might get pissed of me too i got to do
that and you know with jordan love and
everything he might not be at the place
where aaron rodgers is as far as certain
plays checks the totality of the offense
to where they might not be able to
really practice what they want to do so
just from an x's and o's football
standpoint
you do want the guy like aaron rodgers
to be there for for those factors
and to the point that you made back when
this all got started
he should want to be at everything in
the off-season because it slams the door
on the ability of jordan love to develop
to the point where the packers may say
we're good to go we're good to go we
were right when we traded up to get
jordan love in the 2020 draft we're
comfortable with him he's developed and
i remember when
and this wasn't that long ago and at the
same time it was a long time ago in
2016 when
one of the
breathless talking points from those of
us in the media was the fact that marcus
mariota then a rookie with the titans
had thrown no interceptions right in
training camp right he's got no
interceptions aaron rodgers came out and
said i want to throw interceptions in
training camp practices because i'm
figuring out the limits yeah of the
extent to which i can trust the receiver
to go catch the ball based upon where i
put it relative to where the defender is
exactly i want those things to happen in
training camp so if he's not there for
otas if he's not there for mandatory
mini camp it puts more pressure on
developing that sense of who he can
trust he's got he's got a rookie in
amari rogers that he's he he needs to
get comfortable with who you can trust
when you can trust them where you can
throw it and how it's going to work when
it's time to play in the games that
counts so that's an important part of
being there for the manager no doubt as
well no doubt that's like timing and
rhythm and all those things you talk
about right yeah you're exactly right
hey getting a feel for how my arm feels
this year you know now that i'm a year
older what are the throws that i still
can get away with let me just make sure
i can still do this get away with that
whatever it may be all right so here we
are
it's less than a week what what do you
think do you think he's going to be
there you say no
i don't think he'll be there no you know
he'll be there yeah i don't expect him
to be either i don't i i think it's just
by the fact that he was in hawaii last
week he you know he talked to kenny
mayne about the cleanse he was doing
like i would think he's actually
probably just starting to really train
and get ready for the season right now
and i don't know if he'll be there
either i i i i guess i'm i'm saying no
either i agree and i don't think they're
gonna find him with this uh
and that's still a thing right you don't
automatically why wouldn't they no well
you yeah i don't think they're gonna
want to piss them off anymore i don't
think they want to cause any more i
don't think that's possible well you're
right you're right they might be at the
limit you're right
um and and to borrow a phrase from randy
moss what's 93 000 to aaron rodgers no
it's nothing right right
and he's already given up 500 000 right
by not showing up for at least 85
percent of the offseason program he
sacrificed 500 grand that he otherwise
would have earned so what if he has to
write a check for 93 grand and that's
just the the very small
tip of the iceberg when it comes to the
financial losses he's looking at if he
would go through with
any plan
to not show up at all
in 2021 i broke down the numbers yeah
what's the date if he yeah if he if he
holds out right if he holds out a
training camp and doesn't show up at all
this year the total financial cost is
more than 35 million if he retires just
before start of training camp it's about
33 million so what's 2 million to him
it's still a lot of money for him to
have the privilege of not playing this
year and chris it dawned on me yesterday
i was doing a a spot with paul allen on
kfan and we were talking about some of
the recent reporting
of the aaron rodgers situation and
the light bulb flickered
if you're the green bay packers
and you're looking at the possibility of
trading aaron rodgers right now yeah
you arguably and we've said in the past
you're never going to get more for aaron
rodgers than you're going to get coming
off of the 2020 season when he was the
nfl mvp
but
that
would have been true in march when you
could have gotten maximum teams to the
table right right now you got the
broncos yeah
maybe the raiders
possibly the dolphins if they could
convince aaron rodgers to go to florida
he wants to get closer and closer to the
west coast
if you're the packers
and assuming that you would trade him
now
you're going to get 20 22 draft picks or
later yeah well if you trade him in
march of 2022 that's what you're getting
you're getting the same picks you may
get more picks in march when you can get
seven eight no nine teams yeah to get
involved in the bidding right so
we get more in trade for him if we wait
and then in the interim he either plays
for us another season or we get back 33
million dollars we get 14.7 million in
salary relief that we don't have to pay
him 11.5 million in signing bonus money
6.8 million roster bonus that has been
earned but not paid out yet i was told
recently that those checks are going to
come every week so it's easy to
recapture that as well they don't have
to chase them around right right it's a
lot of money that they could use now or
next year to buy players and they're
going to get more in trade the only
thing they would sacrifice is the
ability to get players who could come in
this year if you're going to trade him
for picks and players yeah sure right
you're not getting the players this year
but if i'm the packers this is a
no-brainer at this point it is aaron
look
we're not trading you this year we'll
we'll consider it in march but we're not
doing it now and we'll see if you show
up and if you do great and if you don't
we'll make do
and we'll we'll realize a significant
pile of cash at a time when the cap is
down and we can use that money now or in
the future to make the team better
elsewhere i agreed with everything you
said there no doubt about it i mean
you're right they're gonna maximize more
you know that's why we questioned rogers
in the first place why wasn't this made
more public if he really wanted to be
traded early on in the offseason to put
the pressure and get it going but yes i
agree green bay has no reason to do
anything right now they can kind of just
sit back yes it's all on aaron rodgers
he's he's the guy that's got to make the
next move and 35 million dollars i don't
give a damn if he got you know you're a
billionaire or you got 200 million in
the bank that's a lot to just say i'm
gonna walk away from that this year
that's that's that's i i mean even for
people as much money as rogers or brady
or the other top quarterbacks man that's
a tough one to walk away from and
you know how many years do you have left
how many years you have left you're
going to give up one of your remaining
years you've got four years that's where
i'm going 25 of it yeah no doubt about
it that's exactly it and that's where i
was going to go with this so i don't
think he'll be at mini camp he'll be a
training camp i'm gonna be interested to
see if they really find him because
stars in my history and the league and
knowing it usually don't get fined and
they might not want to add fuel to the
fire here but that'll be interesting
nonetheless but but i think your point
there what you just said is the real
thing is that the clock is ticking
rogers is special he's one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time but
not everybody thinks that in a lot of
ways i don't think the public thinks
that and to me like you're saying too
here
limited amount of gears we've talked
about this the team's good right now
they could go to a super bowl again we
know we like to have we'd like them to
have a little more firepower all right
but the other thing with rogers and we
know how hyper aware he is is the legacy
thing and all that the other thing i
always come back to is like
roger's part of his like the super bowl
thing's over for rogers yeah maybe he
can get one or two more right he ain't
going to catch brady he's not catching
terry bradshaw or montana at this point
i don't think i mean we'll see
one more i think would be great for him
but either way part of his legacy is
going to be his stats that's going to be
it i mean when you look at aaron rodgers
stats they they blow you out of the
water like we've talked about a few
weeks ago the 400 touchdown passes less
than 100 interceptions you know quickest
of 40 000 yards quickest to 300
touchdowns he's gonna be the quickest to
all these numbers as we keep going and
just think about what he did last year
it was half a hundred touchdown passes
and five interceptions you know he's
he's the last three years it's a hundred
touchdown passes or 99 something like
that and like ten or nine interceptions
i didn't do the math but it's somewhere
like that so to me that's part of his
legacy too and i think he's got to be
aware of that to like yeah you're
missing a great year of your career you
could win a super bowl and then you know
some of the things you said and that
part of it right there that's where i
just think rogers will be back playing
football
over under his status on the all-time
passing yardage list 10.5 over or under
uh
oh i think he's under right now yes he's
under he's over is he over he's at
number 11. okay he is
230 yards away from john elway to crack
into the top 10. okay the others ahead
of him three of them are active matt
ryan with 55 right 767 rogers has 51
245. ben roethlisberger is at 60 000 and
change and and tom brady obviously it's
79 000 he'll catch drew brees possibly
week four sunday night on on uh nbc and
you know it's amazing rogers became the
starter in 2008
matt ryan became a starter in 2008 yeah
matt ryan's got 4 500 more passing yards
than aaron rodgers yeah no it is and
when you look at a base level but i
would also say like the last few years
and things like that
you know of course hey first off matt
ryan's had more talent on the offensive
side of the ball around him his whole
career that that's undeniable i mean so
that that's conversation's over and then
the other part is
yeah they i mean especially the last few
years and there's some other years too
where
you know they're not as good they're
down so he gets to throw a ton and gets
to get a lot of yards that way as well
but hey matt ryan yeah he's put up a lot
of damn stats there's a lot better than
i think people want to give him credit
for for sure but the touchdown passes
the interceptions rogers has a chance
there still he does yes you know so
that's where he's seventh i think pete
just said in my ear in all-time
touchdowns yeah passes 412 right he's
ahead of rothersburger he's ahead of
ryan the only one he's trailing is tom
brady with 581 but he is eight away from
dan marino nine away from phillip rivers
and there's a gap of nearly 90 to catch
brett favre oh yeah that's so he's got a
lot he's got a lot of work there and
that i mean again if you want to get up
there to the brady peyton manning drew
brees territory and all these stats you
can't take a year off i mean that that
ends that and to me i just feel like the
guy's too aware of all these things and
where he is in the pantheon of all time
great quarterbacks and everything like
that the super bowl thing's not going to
be there so the stats are important too
and i just i can't imagine roger's
walking away for a year just to prove a
point here
assuming 40 a year and that's that's
yeah
that's he needs four years to catch drew
brees there you go four years right 40 a
year to catch up
and the one name i mentioned is the most
important brett favre at 508 no doubt
about you know there is no way he is
walking away from football until he gets
to 509. i i would no
i would think he knows all these numbers
i mean he just he he does he you know he
it slips out every now and then when you
hear an interview too he's very aware of
like my my stats this guy's stats what's
what's the history of football he really
knows that type of stuff and then you
know the last thing mike too that we've
hit on many times but i do think it's a
real fact and like something that's you
know tangible is he has no issue with
the coaches or the players like we've
talked about so when you come back to
that you you can block the guten coos
and everybody else out of your life uh
when it comes to football and the front
office people to where it won't affect
you on a day-to-day basis because you
don't have to see them or deal with them
as much as long as they stay away from
the practice field as we've said if you
go near
if you go near the white line brian
goody coons two cops stand behind rogers
stand behind visor
shoulder pads
flak jacket body guard
be ready to go right are you ready to go
um
yeah so and and this all feeds into why
the packers are doing what they're doing
they're calling his bluff if it is a
bluff if it's a bluff we call if it's
not a bluff we'll live yes
if he's not going to show up
fine
fine we'll we'll go forward with jordan
love
and we'll deal with it after the season
so you know what
we had
suggested last week and and i know the
packers are aware of the possibility of
him retiring for a year and then coming
back next year when they will have moved
on
i
i think they'll move on if he doesn't it
doesn't matter what happens this year if
jordan loves good enough he's the guy
next year if not they'll find somebody
else i don't think they're going to pin
their hopes to aaron rodgers if he sits
out all of the 2021 season but i don't
think he will and and maybe he holds out
some of the training camp just to send a
message i don't know
but the message is sent we know we're
aware aaron that you're upset with the
front office we get it it's about the
people we understand i don't know what
further message he can send
that would convince anyone of his
position without undermining his ability
to get his 40 touchdowns this year chris
yeah no that that's exactly right i mean
he's kind of stuck now at this point
this part of the year and i think you
explained it right with with the packers
and their situation as well you know i
mean i i feel like the writing's on the
wall here with the fact that they
haven't budged and everything like that
i mean
a lot of that says it's roger's just
playing to see if he can get another
gear in green bay anyways they don't
they don't seem like yeah like they're
batting at eye like oh man we might have
to go with jordan love in 2022 and go
you know go from there
i think those are the kind of the
messages they've sent to rogers probably
why it's pissed him off he hasn't got
enough of that you know uh
yeah what am i trying to say commitment
from them right to to feel good
right or wrong
accurate or inaccurate he thinks
that he threw a wrench in their plan
last year by being the mvp the plan
therefore being to flip the switch from
aaron rodgers to jordan love in 2021 he
believes that i know doesn't matter
whether it's true right he believes it
and that that's one of the reasons and
so you know what chris
now that we've talked this through
and we both believe this is going to end
up with aaron rodgers showing up for
training camp
why not just go to the mandatory mini
camp why not no i know what's the harm
in going there is none you're right go
practice play unless you want to torture
brian good that's what that's what i
think he'll do exactly right that's
where i think that's all that's what i
think it's about it's just like one more
you know screw you jab to the head and
be like i you know i'm just not coming i
don't feel it right now i don't want to
answer the questions you guys answer
more of the questions i i think that's
what it's about you're right everything
else you just go yeah go get better take
away the reps from jordan love like
we've talked about your team's good
let's start getting going uh but no i
think he's a you know a stubborn sob and
i say that politely in an endearing way
in a lot of ways uh that he won't do
that
here's the key though
when you don't show up for something
that is
mandatory yeah you commit an overt act
that will give the fan base reason to
shut down sure and the people who cover
the team
reason to
that fire so while you torture brian
gooda kunst for another six weeks you're
also torturing the fan base for another
six weeks so that's the other side of
this to the point he's trying to win the
crowd and
i think we agree that that whole people
persons paper people routine from last
week was about winning the crowd
not showing up for mandatory mini camp
that that's going to be a tough one to
explain
when the time comes to get the fans on
your side because they're going to spend
six weeks pissed off that you weren't
there for mandatory mini camp but if you
slip up at all this year ah if you had
to come to mandatory minicam you'd be
better prepared for the season
it's that's where it's it's it's a weird
topic
yeah i i i
mean when you say it that way too it
makes me think man gosh he's shown a lot
of times in history that he is hyper
aware of that type of stuff too
and that he'll be there so i i mean i
have no idea i ha i would think that
matt lafleur has no idea at this point
either and they'll get a feel i would
say this weekend whether rogers is
coming into town saturday friday matt
lafleur might hear from rogers then to
go you know what do you think i'm going
to come into town or i might miss
whatever but i think your point there is
very real public pressure rogers aware
of that and when you say that it makes
me think yeah maybe there is a little
bit more of a chance that he does show
up
and and let's remember
this because it's now been several years
the 60 minutes profile that was done of
aaron rodgers included comments from
teammates and a general vibe that aaron
rodgers is very sensitive yeah right and
he bristled at that and 60 minutes
issued a statement in response to his
complaint that was essentially see he's
proven
he's so sensitive he's sensitive about
being called sensitive so
this is this is the whole human being
that is making this decision and we have
to consider that he does not like to be
criticized he does not like to be called
out he does not want the cheeseheads
to
to to think ill of him yeah and maybe he
maybe he will be there i know
it's fascinating it's going to be a
fascinating aaron rodgers psychological
experiment next tuesday we're going to
get to dive deeper into his brain and
see where he's at with that
and either he shows up or he doesn't but
either way we'll have plenty to discuss
he'd be talking about the reaction to
him not showing up or whatever he says
when he rolls into camp and oh his
attitude is what's the big deal why the
media made a big deal of this why you
this is all fake news you're all this is
all your fault not my fault i can't wait
for that oh me too i wouldn't bet
against it happening please aaron
rodgers say don't look at mike florio's
crap and say that give us a great
headline
we've been using that clip for five
years now boom there it is come on get
out of here reading crap like that
that is so good how he delivered it it
was so good
he when you watch all of it yeah he
really didn't want to do it right you
could see you could see you could see
the dilemma playing out you can almost
if you if you look just right you can
see the devil on one shoulder and the
angel on the other trust me aaron i'm
there every single day and the devil
the devil wins his share of battles
hopefully he hasn't won the war yet
there it is we need him
we need we need to do this
there was a little everything in that
face there he didn't want to say and you
know what you know what since we went
there let's remember
that comment was made by him
because i was looking at things he was
saying to the media that year saying
he's got a problem with mike mccarthy
and what have we learned since then
chris yeah what have we learned he had a
problem with mike mccarthy you're listen
it's you know people can say what you
want you're phenomenal at connecting
dots and your pasta and meatballs gut
and going with it and you were all over
that and a hundred percent correct so
yeah that was a good call by you and
you're right that was another instance
of putting together pieces to where we
hey we we know how you feel
even though
we don't know because you haven't said
so
and this gets back to and this is the
last thing i'm going to say about it he
doesn't like it when he gets called out
on his passive aggressive comments he
wants to be able to say those things and
send those messages and he doesn't want
us
and any of the rest of us in the media
to say
you know what he said
here's what he means right here's who
he's saying it to he doesn't want us to
do that he wants to have it both ways he
wants to be able to throw the dart and
not be accused of throwing the dart it's
that simple chris i agree mike i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna push back there you
know you know this this is my guy and
there's a lot that i love about him and
i love sometimes where he is honest and
does things like that but yeah he can be
cryptic there's no doubt about that and
i'm not going to deny that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports